el primer día de la libertad como es
considerado el día de hoy aquí en
inglaterra es vivido con una mezcla de
emociones mientras el gobierno defiende
la liberación de todas las restricciones
sociales y la reapertura del país la
gran mayoría de la población y los
expertos consideran que es muy temprano
para acabar con el uso obligatorio del
tapabocas de la mascarilla en el
transporte público y en lugares cerrados
hemos aquí en el suroeste de londres
recorrido algunos supermercados y
algunos comercios y la gente está usando
todavía este tapabocas también los
expertos celebran el avance de la
vacunación aquí en el reino unido- más
de 82 millones de personas han recibido
entre la primera y la dosis completa de
la vacuna pero también creen que es muy
complejo esta liberación cuando los
casos de la variante delta están
especialmente disparados y con ello
también las hospitalizaciones algunas
voces en el parlament o incluso creen
que en el otoño sería posible un nuevo
confinamiento por la liberación de estas
medidas tan rápido